hey guys sounds like it's Justine I'm
here with Jenna we are in my kitchen and
today we're where are we we're in my
kitchen so easter is coming up and users
one of my favorite holidays and what I
think about Easter I think about
marshmallows probably because of peeps
which feels like what peeps ro and I did
a massive peep taste test
that was crazy I think last year we did
the chubby bunny challenge with the
peeps I think well today we're gonna be
stuffing marshmallows this says it right
here place and twist it crunch it fill
it stuff it dip it I was gonna repeat
lluvia song but I got it Barna do it
press it snap it work it quick erase it
oh it's also um talk with fun stuffed
with magic so many ways to yum let's
open this box I kind of look like a
giant marshmallow I didn't want to say
anything what are you trying to apply it
along oh I got tricked again what's the
age on this is there like a limit like
what if you're thirty years over the
limit
I'm not let me your step packs you
attach the peg to the arm peg to the arm
I am an adult and this doesn't make
sense
this wooden mess what week we fill
marshmallows not included now you place
the funnel on top of the order okay what
do you love universe how do we make this
enough what do we do
Hunter and mixer [__] up so cruncher
mixer wait this is some cruncher that
makes me way more sense now that's the
that's the poor top yeah we're gonna
pour this inside this mole oh it's for
four-year-olds
mix icing in your other mixing Cup so
this is two parts icing so what does one
part mean like half of this one part
what one part water two part icing oh
[Music]
I'm not that's that's gooey
I've been gooed do you think we should
put some powdered sugar in it make the
more icing Oh No okay bad idea P Sugar's
high just over time to get so far we got
a little more than that let's put this
rock in there oh now I'm slimed okay so
while you're doing that I'm gonna just
stab this is that it did that did that
penetrate the mohel do we put this in
there no we still have a screen cool
this is so silly
it's for four-year-olds what do you
expect it's so silly like I haven't
finished hidden what we're doing
[Music]
I don't think it's been penetrated you
pour it in and then you stick this and
it shoves it into the hoof that's in
there that's something that's something
to write home about
well don't waste all your sprinkles in
one mallow oops oh my gosh oh god I
think I'm allergic to something like I
mean I've got an itch J that's that's
that's too much in there because you
hate me I'm not sure cruel I can ask one
freaking marshmallow until it's broken
its step to the max take it out take it
out doffed gonna be decently should I
get a plate - yeah this is beautiful
get out of my way connect with can I put
other stuff in there what do we have
chocolate chips yes say thank you use
the other side and another make way more
sense okay stick it in this actually is
quite enjoyable yeah that's a lot shove
it and it's a shot in there get in there
okay I think that's good now let's put
some more lows let's jam no feels very
full super feels extremely heavy this
would be heaviest marshmallow they've
ever held oh wait oh yes holy right
isn't it happy 14 pounds it's happy 14
pounds you know what we should put in
here drugs it's a joke it's a joke
Doakes Oh God well I think worth is a
crunch this what are you tastes like
their little chicka chicka chicka chicka
chicka cheap that one's gonna be heavy
this is extremely awesome uh you know
what we should do
melt a marshmallow and put it inside the
marshmallow she hates it she hates the
idea well you know what you see dancing
you coming up with many unique ideas
let's fill it with gold
oh jeez Oh wheeze careful cuz it's gonna
fly out of it stick it in good
there you go I felt well I felt wow I
felt worried I don't think I don't feel
good about what's gonna happen am i
allergic to marshmallow
oh oh that's full well when do we get to
break them open and see what's inside
I don't like Alice's oh look how much
crap was gonna eat this no I'll eat it
No
it's like I'm eating rocks marshmallow
for glass let's go glasses oh look at
that nothing there's hardly any in there
that's a lot very tiny marshmallow you
got Jam it fool like this one
save some for a picture let's do another
one Jen shall we
[Music]
ripped out way better than our Easter
video I'll just say that spoiler alert
I'll try this line it's plain do you
want to eat it Cheers
I don't really like sprinkles no I don't
even like marshmallows I don't either
all right guys don't thank you so much
for watching I hope you guys enjoyed
this this is actually really really cool
I would definitely recommend getting
this for a child I think that if you
were a child you will love this I as an
adult also loved it it was fun it was a
bit easy it's actually was pretty cool
out of all of the children's toys that I
have tried I think this is actually
probably my favorite it's incredible it
actually worked a lot better than I
thought all right guys I'll see you soon
go check out Jenna's channel and come
back on Saturday because we've got a
very fun little Easter surprise for you
like an Easter disaster mm-hmm
okay bye oh god now I have to clean up
[Music]